that's right that's right he ha he IE
ight hey Boober
hey rinks hey big gay al I'm talking
over there y'all [ __ ]
hey our show in Pasadena sold out so
don't even bother you can just refer to
me its ranks boomer and old [ __ ] yeah I
can't boomer no don't call me boo
boomerang boomer ranked a keg al a ke
break ranks shut up you Italian leggo mm
thanks next warts nope you're yet come
up with your own dude yeah you look like
the guy who makes smoothies for pee did
and Drake dude yeah I'll get bigger you
[ __ ] overgrown walrus Oh getting
there boomer
either way this boomers I'm not a Boomer
all right a Bobby in Kansas City next
weekend December 6 through the seventh
I'm looking for the best barbecue I'm
bringing jokes those shows almost sold
out Friday Saturday then December 14th
one night only Borgata New Jersey we're
doing some comedy I bring my squad at
the Borgata casino in Atlantic City one
show only and then where I'm staying
around watching the big UFC fights with
you hoodlums let's have some fun
La Hoya December The Comedy Store
December 19th 21st
Oklahoma City the 27th toll so the 28th
get your tickets T fat K calm calm
come see me celebrity theater in Phoenix
December 21st and then when I got the
Boston I got the Boston Wilbur New
Year's Eve get your tickets 12 31 19 I'm
there one show only I'm excited you
sound like you and we got Nashville keep
at kake.com
Nashville Tennessee back hey hey
national chief actuary hey you [ __ ]
ten-year-old stop looking
throw up - you're full of [ __ ]
mischief Nashville January 9th 10th
louver just see the big gay al come get
sucked off on the New Year's hey man
let's start the podcast you piece of
[ __ ] all right
you know what it is man when I was a
young warthog when I was a young warthog
when I drink coffee I'm always looking
for that little high I get that little
spark oh I can't anymore it's hard to
get I got it this morning with my first
cup then you're chasing it all day you
chasing the dragon [ __ ] John a dragon
chasing the java java dragon bro you
know what it is what I hate yet and I've
been doing this lately yeah you okay
that's one well that's one way that the
Devils dandruff yeah but you could do
yeah I like to add a shot to my drip
coffee I go I'll take your darkest rose
add a shot also known as a red-eye yeah
that'll put some hair on you yeah Cole
yeah my friend was a police officer not
happy with his job when he was younger
and he would go to the Starbucks and the
woman would shake her head and I was
like why she's shaking her head I was
with him and she goes you'll see when
she goes usual and then she turns she
goes six shots in one cup yeah he would
do that four times well I told you
what's the only way to keep his [ __ ]
head exploded this is well well Jesus
something he needs to talk to me he's
not a guy [ __ ] a chicken I told you
that right yeah yeah and he caught
another guy mmm well anyway it's a tough
gig um well I told you the time
well-documented he can go back to look
at when I was doing Rogan and I stopped
at the Starbucks before and I got the
cold brew the draft and I go can you add
a shot to that and she goes oh we don't
we can't add shots that you can't
technically do that you well I can my
caffeine level tolerance is so high
throw the shot in there back throw the
shot in there throw the shot in there
job a [ __ ] yep and then she goes well
we can't do it okay so here's what we
can do
I'll take a large draft and a side of
expresso she goes no we can do that
espresso try it drives me crazy espresso
and I said okay I'll do that
so they do that through the shot in
there
downed it one Rogen's dude I [ __ ] my
pants oh yeah you got a boom you gotta
prove right now he's reading like here
do it dude you got to be careful very
careful yeah peppers will do that to me
and so a coffee fight a lot of hot
peppers like that howling chicken and
caffeine oh that's trouble my butthole
goes I got quit eating a barbecue before
you stand up it's so heavy too heavy
everyone's so time except with whiskey
got a problem yeah look at some barbecue
outside to here I don't know where that
from do we know what's wrong I think it
brought him for the holidays you see all
the barbecue out there I guess I left
here have you there's a giant thing of
barbecue out there how was that song
like fantastic a lot of Mormons a lot of
whites our whites a lot of Mormons yeah
a lot of sister wives now I got roamed
around the temple sure John Smith's
temple the 14 year old who you want to
see books lost him don't remember went
yeah anyways but when you roam around
there they're sisters yeah and you go
hey fellas I said hey sister jasmine
wait is it John Smith John Smith right I
think so and let's say you said John
Smith yes John Smith John Smith the
founder that's right you found the books
they're over there Joseph Smith a loss
of the lost Joseph Johnson Spence : John
I knew it was different it was Joseph
shove his friends call him John make oil
salesman initially you know that
actually sold snake work correct action
JIT snake then found then found the
tablets lost them and then found them
again I guess yes now he rolled and
tablets yes the Ellen tablets use 14 we
did all this mind you smart guy smart
guy
now you can clown Scientology and
Hubbard all you want but
Scientology Mormon very similar well
actually I would I have to define Mormon
I like both of them oh no I have to
defend Mormonism for a second because
he's due it's it's actually in a lot of
ways whatever they do a lot of times
works make tight families I know there
are issues in any every religious
community but very good economically
they they are they owned that town built
that town its Salt Lake City works it's
it's it's just a special place now is
this life being a Mormon is also
learning to not be be beholden to the
devices
a lot of sex even caffeine a lot of good
Mormons won't take a selfie or alkyl
yeah so the idea is your soul doesn't
want to be connected to him being a give
yeah I like that idea I can't do it I
don't but it's pretty devious and live a
little and there's a reason why coffee
beans they would argue that they do and
they would argue that they have big
families and close friendships and
community it's very very tiny having
close family close connections and I
suppose shitload of coffee yeah we're
all gonna have but they but the idea of
going out there to make the world a
better place for non-mormons and even
converting them is the idea they have to
go on mission they do that's no joke
then so when I when we walked around the
Joseph Smith arena or whatever it is the
church grounds anyone can go on there
I want Derek and asana go with me
because once a black guy went to Indian
I don't see the looks they got fantastic
so we walk in and then the sisters
walked around they come go do you [ __ ]
do you fellas need any help answering
questions I went we have a ton of
questions I said sister Marie where do
we start
yeah and then she started going and then
she goes I go there's no do to round
we're all the guys she goes well they're
out on their missions know what oh you
guys stay here the women stay here and
the guys go out and what streets are
rough out there right joke failed they
didn't appreciate it because women don't
go on mission do they it's men it's
dangerous dude right so you have the
dudes well you know my buddy who who is
a what's the word a CIA guy or maybe
just a guy who works for the government
in different ways he said if you want to
get if you want your daughter to be at
very high risk of rape have her join the
Peace Corps
yeah in a lot of countries it's [ __ ]
know what I think Girl Scouts don't go
door to door yeah well my daughter had
to dare when she was a girl scout
anymore well no she had to go get signed
petitions but Oh daddy
Oh daddy was lingering they wanted to go
by herself well do you have a phone but
I was I was when I'm dad - dad was right
I what I'm doing you know you know 30
feet away you know pop shops doing
faking those signatures oh we're not
doing go door-to-door that's that's a
girl scouts the first of all your own
[ __ ] you first of all you have boys I'm
not a girl boy scout you definitely
doing boys have you seen this speaking
of trans transexual
in what in the nola speaking of well no
cuz we're talking about men and women
well look up Hannah mmm MOU and Cey
Hannah Moon see oh you talk about a
tick-tock look in the water I'm talking
about a man who is now a woman who is on
a mo n she's an Australian athlete she a
lot she's very vocal about policies and
sport that discriminating against trans
women okay
now this used to be a man but what's the
problem well take a look Oh
get gotten take a look at the size you
want a Manning rugby well there there
there you go that's uh there's like is
good luck there there she is look
tackling Mike Alstott with a wig on well
that's what it is
I mean it's she's is fine hilarious
although I see you got to see the video
she's so much bigger that doesn't do it
justice do you got some video of her
well it'd be Clay Matthews everybody
well yeah that's Clay Matthews you know
but playing with women rugby that's I'm
sure she's very vocal about how
discriminatory I shall know rugby by the
way but she's just truck in hose oh she
is it's that first six to 220
transgender that weighs oh [ __ ] oh my
god she's playing that handball - oh
come on aren't you if you're here don't
you want to play with men though Wow
come on dude what's the point nobody
else and no one's cheering though let me
see it well let me see the rugby one
though that's handball wearing is gay
either way you put it but it's [ __ ]
hilarious
yeah let's see the truck these girls
know Wow really honey dicta
wait that's is that sixteen there it is
sixty minutes one uh okay so he's got a
hand will be all showing this Jedi he
was an elite athlete oh [ __ ] he's on
Team Austrailia handball poor guy they
has to be tough for him yeah that's fine
it's tough for him but they can make it
my problem where you're you're leveling
women
keep on with the van why would you want
to hear an elite athlete among men
you're a giant dude he's also six -
something like what just join its it's
such a it's such a it's so quaint there
but also if you're a star you know my
god that way but if you're a star girl
player and you could dominate the men
they would come over and do it don't you
think yeah like why wouldn't he if let's
say you definitely be a woman just play
with the dudes they're not a equal right
just go play about the cereals and size
of the dudes we may be a woman but play
with the day I feel like a woman but
your play have to do Oh what's the
matter cuz you're taking extra estrogen
it makes you weaker and nobody wants the
same thing because Australia is so
[ __ ] politically correct and it's
like I don't get [ __ ] wear wig hook
up with you you have a boyfriend to your
lead for you on the side I don't get off
there's something wrong I'm sorry I'm
sorry but also like hey it's I it's on
him or her it's on it's on that new
problem and it's on you brah [ __ ] up
it's like you you you should know better
your Chi it's basically cheating 44 I'm
not gonna say you shouldn't be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] how we all feel
we have 44 God okay I don't blame god
damn it Greg
I know go play with your own [ __ ]
people man
that's more a very big strong person you
know so [ __ ] also unstoppable with
the wind oh yeah it'd be like it's like
you playing with me it's not correct but
it's no different if Dwight Howard was
like I feel like a woman put on a wig
and playing WM behave like dude what are
we doing dude I [ __ ] love help
somebody ask me when you when Shopp was
when you guys are doing jiu-jitsu what
was was like did took him a little while
ago why did you say did you see the
video we were joking then I was like I
can't do he thought it was actually
getting you or something I was like
you'd never watch you don't hang about
it would be the same way I mean it's
like
but even at least you're not a dude for
both dudes this is even less than that
more do it's like mean cat to be honest
what I always say is that men who hit
women like who should have to be have to
get into a ring with a guy like you they
should have to go oh you like to hit you
like to beat up women you like a tough
guy I want you to roll with
Brendan Schaub right now who think Greg
Hardy says hold my beer I'm gonna jump
in the Aki on your pretty yeah
let's move on did you see Charles
Barkley just [ __ ] that do you see
Charles Barkley had to apologize cuz he
told that one reporting cuz I don't hit
women but if I did I'd hit you I thought
it was funny but to get to issue an
apology in know Charles Barkley apology
like Charles Barkley yeah he basically
said once you have to reporter accusin
wife telling her I don't hit women but
if I did I would hit you which I don't
know why it's kind of funny but I don't
know why he said that did she say some
to him it was attempted a joke that
wasn't funny at all there's no excuse
for it at all I apologize of course she
just FYI Charles Barkley told me tonight
I don't hit women but if I did I'd hit
you and then I objected to that he told
me I couldn't take a joke well all
because Berkeley came talking about how
he loves Duval Patrick and wants someone
from Pete campaign came around he said
he loved Pete and I remind him he
previously said he was a Duvall fan
oh that's why so he's joking around all
axiom come on can't they put him on
blast though yeah they better not
I would hey everybody don't ever
interview interview me again I can't
trust you I'm joking around you can't
take context yeah I mean you know it's
fine to come and reprimand me personally
say I made me feel uncomfortable back
I'm really sorry I'd make amends do you
or you put me on blast you know what's
interesting I was in Salt Lake City over
the weekend right they have a giant car
malone statue there so i just started
looking in the carmel own little bit of
a dark past had no idea karma
yeah you know you got a
thirteen-year-old pregnant when he was
20 i didn't know that's a big problem
you know what happened that kid went on
playing the NFL for six years and then
he called carmel own when you got to the
NFL okay what kid that that kid with a
thirteen-year-old so carmel own was 20
yeah I had sex with 30 no she got
pregnant
oh and that kid went on that kid got
drafted in the NFL holy [ __ ] and but
then he called caramel or caramel
I want nothing to do with you do I have
my own family like I was 20 when this
happened I'm not your dad
that's that's pretty dark the mailman
huh
but didn't but then again he's playing
in the NFL that's pretty well yeah but
you'll have a dad no wait he viewed it
was just like caramel is it just a donor
and I grew up with my mom and then
shareholder in the NFL sure but that's
nuts
you know yeah I had no idea oh is that
caramel own you know dude jail time for
that though I don't know that yet
twenty-year-old with a 13 year old
that's trouble right that's very that's
does that say yeah I think that's going
on unconscious the whole world's really
curricular Fair this weekend even though
my daughter be 12 soon I can tell you
that's a child his almost completed or
it began service on sending with Buffalo
Bills Kraft offensive tackle Demetrius
Bell from Northwestern State in the
seventh round it was known that Bell's
mother raised him on her own Bo's also
noted that his father was Karl Malone
former power forward for the Utah Jazz
Los Angeles Lakers but he just jump on
its own I don't know yeah no idea
oh there we go did you sleep there Jim
the Buffalo News followed up the
security appeared to be bills most 13 at
the time its birth Malone that time was
a college sophomore Louisiana Tech I
hate to do this but she might have been
as young as 12 then there's a
possibility so the law says she was 13
yeah those the Los Angeles Times has
also mention aside from a few blogs
they've seen no mention of this any of
the major media now neither bail his
mother nor him alone have denied this
story so I find rather curious that
their major media have failed after oh
well interesting right mm-hmm and then
the only thing I saw it with if you ask
are my Karl Malone oh there it is did
you guys know Karl Malone made amends
with his coat on that chin the very last
one it's just a blog one it says on in
1984 the 20 year old NBA legend caramel
on a child's 13 own when he was
sophomore college
he denies paternity never public
committed despite DNA confirmation the
son Demetrius Bell was an NFL player for
five years Wow said he only met his
father once on one occasion after you
graduated high school when moon told him
it was too late for a father-son
relationship you'd have to make it it on
his own he made it on his own though
didn't he
if you're Carmelo no you're 20 sophomore
I mean having sex with 30 no it's just
insane but they the only thing I can say
the only thing is it was this 13 year
old did he know she was 13 or did he
think she was 20 we don't know and and
and can you be fooled by say 13 oh hold
on puberty here it goes it says although
Malone was 28 years old at the time that
the 13 year old Gloria Belle was
impregnated she said that the her family
chose not to pursue criminal charges
against Milan a relationship corna bell
with Malone being a neighbor well he's
the neighbor her family not wish to see
him jailed assistance you would then be
unable to provide child support hmm well
I don't know man I mean that's that's
called Karl Malone got lucky on that one
I'll tell you that much well had another
problem cuz 1989 mamonde busting nuts
y'all 1989 Malone was also sued over
paternity of twins Darryl and Cheryl
Ford also Sommerfeld Louisiana simile to
the case with Belle the for twins case
was ultimately sailed out of court and
without Malone offering confirmation
that he was the twins father the
paternity suits became public London
acknowledges pertaining about the four
twins she entertained I so Belon Belon
twins are close yeah dude
again again though like you're having
kids and then just ignoring them I have
no time for that my only thing is when
when he's 20 and he's a sophomore in
college so I make to the NBA any a13
I'll prep the 13 I'll think they were
unforgivable let's say she was of legal
age which is a big let's say I get not
be able to figure it out you know just
your 20 think I wasn't knuckling you
imagine having two kids one
so he makes mistakes I'll give him that
but the 13 opening on staff right I mean
it to me it's crazy how they kept it all
under wraps that's what this was today
it'd be tough hey you'd have to fork out
so much money for now but now you have
to deal with the police
well you but that's what the cops oh
they didn't go to the police so they
could have just he could have paid his
way through it handsome dude there is
and that's his son his daughters are hot
to some place where LSU they're gorgeous
people oh they are man she's gorgeous
he's a stud he's a super stud dude they
would have won them before is that his
son right there the other guy the guy
for LSU
it's a family or is that his steps or is
it like his I don't know is he a grandpa
now or soon if you had a kid at his
other kid it's like 40 well at the end
of the day hopefully that kids playing
the NFL it's a big deal no he's not
anymore
yeah son that's him right no that's not
the one that was shown right there I'm
assuming AJ Dimitra spell KJ probably
plays for the mustache yeah he plays for
LSU yeah currently six for 302 pounds
office I got a small kid my lord
well Katie ran a five three in the 40
not great hmm good thing you don't
really give a [ __ ] up here often Simon
yeah a little dark side to Carmel own
the mailman bring that dark mail you
feel me now did you watch the I'm sure
the fight between Ortiz and sure did
dude
yeah which think I think that Ortiz is
40 and I think that John T Wilder hits
like everybody says impossibly hard and
uh you know people say that to me
Deontay Wilder camp box like he's not a
boxer which is compared to Tyson Fury
technique-wise it's flash again
did you watch fire to see the highlight
did watch the fireworks fight and I saw
him lose every round to get out class
technical technical got outclassed yeah
lost every round that's right let me
come with the right hand that's right
yes that's the problem is that that
fundamentally he's not on the same level
is not fury
he's
Josh no but he has that gift from he's
like the hella crazy gift he's got that
how do you train it you can't make one
mistake your boy what it looked like was
that Ortiz in the sounds around got
tired he looked like he was standing
there and he was blocking and then he
just for a second he dropped his hands
he looked while he's we had a whole time
some was like you reset and then boom
water-jug losing every [ __ ] around
but that's true
I I just am very curious Letta mentally
technical like Ortiz definitely the I'm
sorry while there's definitely the war
7/3 there's no question is the most
useful tool there it's nuts crazy can
shut the game down
I don't know III it's but it makes the
division very exciting because Dione
Towada can still lose if you avoid that
right hand big if no one has it big if
no one no one has you and fury do it no
way to see is for you didn't avoid it I
know I get a draw look you see that he's
got he's got his hands waiting for it
all night in range that was the only he
just got a little tired there just got
up for a second I look pretty good man
that's that's more Wilders skilled level
then Ortiz taking it easy up it's right
down the pipe right then the pipe booth
and just couldn't get back up well you
know who I did it oh Jesus his hands are
up you know there yet fury wild are
happening in February for sure enough
you do a fury warrantied yep great fight
great fight
whoa Fury's a slight favorite we liked
up this morning I'm below the belt
slight favorite cuz obviously Wilder you
know that right hands gonna land while
there has so much self-belief for a guy
who knows he's the I know technically
he's not on their level but he's the
nicest guy ever I bet he's so cool you
know who was awesome I did a food truck
with Maz little on Friday yeah you told
me it's great man yeah just a good dude
special guy really special guy introvert
right does it like the fame takes it
personally no not really
no no he he looked like he was he looked
like when he was about to fight Askren
he when he had his hands man his back
and he looked at him and just smiled he
looked like he was Newseum [ __ ] mom
yeah he was just angry no no he knew he
gonna be able to avoid that rest doesn't
fight angry he's but he knew he's gonna
because when doing so long yeah you
didn't care
he's got just tools such a stud such as
such a good dude
yeah great conversation ah well if he
fights it was fun he's not going to he's
not he's not according to him he doesn't
want to get a food-truck diary but he
gives three other options that he's
gonna do both sides because he's bitter
agree with me he talks about in the end
he's bigger than the title say I don't
care about title it's because I'm little
for big fights money fights those
neither those guys are money [ __ ] yeah
yeah write bigger names Nick Diaz who
else Connor do small jealous than
interview dude is that out it comes out
I think tomorrow interesting dude though
who's out here getting stem-cell hmm
gonna watch it how was New York dude my
family so I'll play called a slave play
the slave controversial play why does he
controversial uh it just just about
black and white relationships and it was
one of the more you written by a guy
named look him up for a sec a young
black writer named [ __ ] Oh Harris is
middle names oh and then Oh dot Jeremy
Oh Harris take a look at him and this
[ __ ] can write this dude has got
sells the play though it was amazing it
was hilarious and ballsy and basically
talking about how when when when you're
it's like like what's starting to happen
is that when you start like there are a
lot of black writers a lot of black
authors now who are writing they're
young and they're going hold on if
you're gonna start talking about how
everything is racist we've heard that
line a thousand times let's let's take a
look at two things we can look at
examine one is let's let's shine the
spotlight back on us what are we doing
let's see what we're doing
second of all let's also take a look at
the fact that maybe we should stop
thinking of black and white with each
other and maybe because we're in a
relationship maybe well let's just this
is what it is you love me I love you
we're both black
yeah I'm black you're white and let's
not mention this there's an idea that
maybe were just people and he doesn't
feel like this white guys like I'm not
white don't say I'm white I don't feel
white and so what am I supposed to call
you off-white you're way more white
tonight you Arab I am black and this is
these really uncomfortable discussions
in the play and it's [ __ ] fascinating
it's fascinating man and and crazy and
and ballsy and nutty and they're doing
this roleplay where one guys playing a
white slave-owner and she's playing it's
crazy and it's like whoever wrote the
guy wrote her is such a ballsy
[ __ ] but but it's it's just an
interesting [ __ ] take is we're
becoming a modern society where a lot of
young kids a lot of young kids like my
daughter and they don't they I'm telling
you there's no prejudice in those kids
because they don't grow up with it that
there's just no judgment they're not
judgmental they don't they're not
thinking black and white they're just
not they're just not when when you're in
school with all that my kids go to a
public school black white Chinese
everything there is none of that it's
just not it's not a reality for them
anymore
and what we're I think I've dared to say
that we're getting closer to a point
where it's just gonna be about you know
what's your economic status I'll hang
with you that way that might be the
dividing line your economic status not
your color did you go to other places
too that was the only one I got to say I
went so much to live music at the olive
tree with those bankers like Christina
Aguilera is a longtime guitarist who can
sing and play anything who sings a
Zeppelin and dusky and then this other
guy who's a genius on the guitar like
you watch these dudes and you I could
sit there all night all night I watched
of Davidoff to stand up and I watch
these you didn't get up but that was a
spectator I took you four days five days
not to perform just to watch just sit
back where I bought some expensive
clothing I'll be the judge oh I know I
bought a pair of jeans in the or ten
percent cashmere all right guy goes it's
got some cashmere in him and I went I'm
in now I go to the duplex I go to the
duplex an old-time piano bar you and I
are gonna do this one day I'm gonna
dress like dandies go to the duplex
watch Jimmy Bursk girlfriend Suze sing
she's a killer
she and see she's a killer she's a
killer and the duplex is where a lot of
Broadway singers start they work as
waiters and bartenders there and they
I'll get up and sing and get the whole
crowd going many of them mani became
Broadway star that's cool
like that's kind of like where you start
it's it's it's a landmark almost like an
open mic for them yes yes yes yes it's a
landmark
it's just gay and and fantastic well you
gave a lot of gays or there's that
musical theater yeah that's cool are you
there a lot hmm you're there like every
night would you say no your cashmere
Jean what well I was in my Cashman's
hearings jeans and a girl I was sitting
across from us who makes those jeans I
go I don't know and she goes I think
they're really sexy and I won't tell my
boyfriend to spend money on jeans and
her boyfriend and I looked at her
boyfriend and I went you gotta buy these
jeans too they're naked and famous but I
like naked a famous yeah well the reason
I buy Naked and Famous the reason I buy
him a story
nope I'm in New York City handsome guy
gets out his wife and her baby of a cab
and the guy looks at me and I'm wearing
I'm just wearing like a [ __ ] jacket
and he goes I was very handsome jeans
very handsome
and I went that's weird to say to me
dude you're big handsome guy you got
your wife and kid I don't know you I'm
about to take your cab what do you mean
he goes naked and famous and I go they
are how did you know that because you
can't see my man he goes I was the stuff
I designed it oh I didn't know that yeah
he designed them oh wow you know you're
addict you know your product no yeah if
you do have them so now that's cool yeah
your favorites are good you can I tell
you what why why I a little bit inside
there covered a lot of reasons I will
never be truly happy right we know this
why man what I'm not when I'm not not
living national athlete okay not built
like one not for you I'm not a big I
don't have it a big easy bone structure
I've got a short femur bone okay I'd
like to have I'd like my legs to be just
a couple inches longer that's all that's
why you're not happy that's ultimately
why you want you're like to have James
look Matt early that's going
you could add some length to my yeah
drink you know yet they like if you
don't want to do that yeah you don't
want to get in today you don't wanna get
in the OL femur bone I break your the
bone you want to add add you know no of
course don't I don't know but it'd be
nice it's one of the most painful
procedures you can do problem because
you can get taller too but they got to
break your bones see I'd like to I'd
like to grow I'd like to have a
well how bad you maybe there's some kind
of a gene thing where you can get a
little growth spurt in your in your 50s
that hate is leg lengthening surgery
worth it click on that leg lengthen is
gaining popular because gives guys or
gals the chance to gain a few it's in
height but some say the pain is not
worth the gain and the us the surgery
costs about $85,000 hmm yeah not I
didn't know you could actually do that
oh yeah
that's nuts what do you do they break
the bone uh and they have the thing
where they inch it supposed to be the
most painful is mad do they add steel to
it or something I look it up chin it
can't feel good
yet suppose me one of those painful
things you can do to get a little some
people have to do it but they I mean if
you so let's see that's interesting
information yeah gives them for me wait
would it cut down on my sprint time the
bone is lessened it's cut metal pins or
screws are placed about the skin and
into the bone pins are placed above and
below the cut in the bone sitter used to
close the wound a metal device is
attached to the pins in the bone it will
be used later to very slowly over months
pull the cut bone apart this great to
space between the ends of the cut bone
that will fill in with new bone month
later and every time the heels they
wreak rack and they recur and then
another to remove the pins Oh several
newer techniques have been developed
this procedure they are based on the
traditional leg lengthening surgery but
may be more comfortable or convenient
for some people ask your surgeon about
the different techniques dude I'm going
on
Rehana var for house drone and I'm
getting a leg lift
uh-huh and we gotta tighten my face up
I'm gonna look [ __ ] Gracie
are you kidding twenty twenty-one think
about how good I'm gonna look I'm
finding I realize how many 33 this can
only give you like maybe two or three
inches that's how you need there's no
way gives you more that's all you need
Anna likes think about it I'd be six one
as opposed to five eleven and [ __ ] a
half or whatever I am oh my god plus I
can main thing I would do it for us so I
can reach people with my round house cuz
I hate being this close
you'd think they'd have some better to
lengthen you if it meant I could kick
you in the [ __ ] face I would bring
you and I'd say I want to be able to
kick this piece of [ __ ] as race how many
inches do I need how many will you kill
five ten no no don't say well first
let's it really knows you're fun we got
to change the movie don't say that don't
say that in dude I'm five do we have a
tape measure so we can measure me right
now we do we do
holy [ __ ] it says jelly the surgery can
add two or three inches inches how tall
do you think I am I think you're between
510 511 all right and I'm gonna say I'm
between 511 six feet get your shoes up
now keep in mind short legs long torso
long neck balling that right right
lunchtime long head - got a point on my
head a head right I have got a weird
head so I my Heights in the wrong parts
of my body we will understand that let
me see it - which is why my roundhouse
kick
[Music]
you are yeah yes yeah 71 inches you
think yeah really yeah let's see that's
curious people always say when they meet
me they go I thought you were shorter
and I'm always taller than you do his
name's to me yes I thought you're
smaller
thank God
well my dad's my dad 6-4 I'll tell he's
gonna be tallest [ __ ] my son oh my god
taller than everybody dad's a large
human being yeah Papa's big you saw him
saw him this weekend oh did you use
that's thick like the great white shark
ivory po retweeted I've seen that big
shark they found biggest great white in
history no go to my Twitter chin this
thing is so thick this great white shark
is so [ __ ] fat thick did they kill it
I'm sure they will they caught it you
know you know how humans do it yeah you
know humans are keep going
right here look a big this look great
white race 20 foot long found near the
island of Oahu where to go wow it's the
biggest on record oh my god but it's
majestic as [ __ ] can I put that shark is
thickest [ __ ] y'all think that thing is
and and so she's swimming with that bad
boy how look at this look there's some
white people [ __ ] here dude you see that
you see the suit though so they don't
confuse confuse it with a seal yeah you
don't want you look like a tiger shark
to pee but how about that oh really cuz
I'll eat a tiger shark nope I made that
up oh but also don't do that right thick
that thing is she's swimming with it
just Cathay just called a shark within
he is she is she breathing she's not
breathing she's holding her breath
who is yes yes she's northland dude
there's no oxygen tank though yes some
nerve dunno the great white shark bro
it's a giant shark that's that's nuts
you be fun guys are swimming with a
giant great white how crazy is that
look at the [ __ ] look at all that is
things been through some [ __ ] man could
be 80 years old we don't know to be a
hundred what do you know one of things I
love to do is scuba dive you know what
I'm in Tahiti I can stay down there all
day long have you been have you been
scuba diving no no no I snorkel bro no
you guys scoot i above you stayed or do
you stay you don't know you don't say
not in Tahiti die hate thee know you'll
never want to come up you'll never want
to come up everything moves in slow
motion like that and you see everything
I snore cool dude I chase Turtles it's
pretty cool that thing's nuts and some
white people [ __ ] for being out of a
[ __ ] box right why she's got a she's
built well little scorpion fish I need
her sorry those are long flip flips huh
she looks like a hot mermaid she does
look at that thing yeah bigger thing is
and they're just chillin in the water
they do say great whites surprised you
know that I didn't know that great
whites were in Hawaii I thought I was
too warm come on bro all right man I
don't know whites are everywhere Flocker
yeah they're huge you gotta see this
problem with ye you have that thing
rolling
yet the tiger the L Tigers they hit the
bull sharks out there as well a lot of
problems that problems mainly tigers
nope Tigers kill more people out there
they
mentioned the man at war as well and
stonefish I've been out there I've seen
he has some locals who are [ __ ] so
it's a can be dicey well you don't have
any surfing because like they say you
can be the King your Beach if you can't
serve Hawaii you ain't [ __ ] and because
it'll take you and smash you a hello
Hawaii though man Hawaii is amazing
let's pot oh why he's amazing this my
spot dude oh are you doing for
Thanksgiving dude we got to show
Wednesday night we got our show wasn't
that girl [ __ ] um sorry about it CJ um
seeing for me no no BJ Yenisei you don't
be a wonderful night oh thanks coming
out Bren theater in minutes at Powell
now introduce the rest of comedy theater
and Phoenix come out I think we're
probably gonna sell out the bed that's
gonna be making that up but no that's
because it's already it's a big its
event I'm at the headliner of the larger
event Schlemmer theater and then Wilbur
theater in Boston I think I'm her first
New Year's right yeah and then I'm gonna
then I'll go to Boston for New Year's
you you know it was not cold in New York
50 degrees I play tennis twice fun Salt
Lake City was freezing it was freezing
freezing [ __ ] freezing for me I don't
know about you the only thing that turns
me into a coward is United safe again
two cowards like who is that Lombardi
said that yeah fatigue makes cowards of
men I think only the curl the coal turns
me into a coward I just don't like grew
up and the only thing cold is your ally
I grew up in the cult did you grow up in
the coffee-room called I was born in the
gold oh I just don't like it it doesn't
bother me I just don't like it you do
okay when you play football in the cold
mom could handle it you're hiring fine
but I hate when they go it's football
weather when it's cold out no it's
[ __ ] uh one says that one of those
guys player hate why do those guys why
do you see those guys just wearing no
sleeves that's just a statement [ __ ] you
know they can feel stuff like I don't
think I'll you guys gonna be all bundled
up but when you're freezing when it's
they put it on like Green Bay I know
those guys are crazy
they're nuts nuts and they're just out
there like a [ __ ] we're doing for
Thanksgiving such children and do at
your house and Amanda and her family
yeah enjoy your house family coming over
yeah yeah her parents my parents are in
New York my dad is my dad
well you're not getting him he doesn't
care you're not getting him out of his
chair if he doesn't like 79
no no I'll come down five blocks have
dinner my dad was like nah I'm like but
I'm your son he's like I've been better
well now he goes you come here you come
here that morning I had I was been so
much easier to get on my plot flight
from Soho and my mother said your
father's waiting oh well you come see
your father up on 57th yeah and ninth I
was like well I'm gonna come see my
father if you live seven nine years I'll
come pay the man I'll come pay my
respect I want to travel and thank you
neither because it's supposed to be
terrible to start and I think Wednesday
Thursday of the early is you seen it
every time but I do and there's a storm
coming though there's a storm no not
because it's just warm the reissuing
can't that flights in Denver could
suppose get bad out there I'll tell you
what you don't want to do is I was your
bag now he'll my friend got her bag
stolen there's surveillance of the guy
they have everything do anything they
don't do anything you can't you never
see it all these United would be like
well we got a wave you never get in your
soup no you just talk about that's the
game maybe you lost your back it sucks
it's what you do yeah what's United
gonna do hire detectives yeah this thing
was [ __ ] in the world oh I'd like to
catch that guy cuz he steals a lot of
bags and you do it I don't expect United
to do it I kick his legs I kick his legs
I kick his [ __ ] knees so he had them
put them in this briefcase and what
possess my pop was here already cuz my
kiddo comes tomorrow dude tomorrow noon
new kiddo comes that's tomorrow
tomorrow but then you stop yeah my kid
comes tomorrow he's born the morning
awesome J comes tomorrow yeah tomorrow
12:30 bro I love how non
sentimental me and Brenda hmm like I
just hear this now like people ask what
were you doing now just say something
about something and there's something
all happen or whatever in pill go so
what would it Brennan say about this
thing and I'm like what do you mean well
what did you see what what happened I go
I don't know we didn't really talk about
it how did you not talk about it we're
not [ __ ] I don't get the whole fans
in town man little deacons tomorrow
12:30 so we're gonna take
about the other way what he detects
c-section how cool Wow
life he has to do a c-section it's
exciting I know kids two big kids are
let's bounce
who knows didn't really matter how big
they're when they're born
like when Tigers born he's like 7 pounds
8 ounces of like it's kind of tiny kid
whatever maybe an active session it was
temp and then right doesn't matter then
two months later
well the [ __ ] up yeah our doctor said
he's like don't worry about what he's
born at it's in three yeah see how they
grow my daughter was born I was like now
my wife is obviously I got a problem
they wanna go well my wife was clearly
[ __ ] an Eskimo so I need the baby
married
the baby looked like me an Eskimo red no
her head was very long number one there
I was like her heads too long yeah
second of all she's we have a long head
she is she looks like an Eskimo please
bring up Inuit bring up anyway here's
the thing man my kid your kid anybody's
kid I've ever seen well they first come
out they are not cute man I'm your [ __ ]
what people say what they tell you my
kid when they first come out it said my
son was hairy I was like he's the father
Andrei Arlovski
why are these these are very cute Inuit
children but that's what she looked like
on the right well no my son was covered
in here shoulders is like neck it was
like what the [ __ ] yeah you babies and I
cute when they first come out and I
don't care what you say man yeah even
the first leg that's a 3 Jesus that's a
senior that's a strong face that's
that's somebody who's lived hard some
would say the hardest the hardest you
live in you live and I want to just do a
little quick thing on the Inuit that's
my guess is I don't know this person
worse but that is somebody who's been
living in the Arctic now what you have
to do is you have to catch a seal so you
can render the fat so you can burn a
lamp and you spend all your time the
winter inside you have to understand
something about the winter sometimes you
don't get a seal and that means you're
not gonna be able to make fire and that
means Owen did I mention that you live
in darkness there long winter you live
in darkness six months of the the
winners all dark you didn't ever the Sun
never Rises I'm Stan so you're always in
the dark and
and you basically sit in the dark and if
you didn't get a seal you live on this
is gonna sound delicious frozen fish
that's what you eat that's we eat and
this one kid said he had a little bow
and arrow a tiny little bow and arrow
they fashioned out of bone stuff and
that's what he played with in his igloo
all day and so he stumbles yeah that's a
good time that sounds like a lot of fun
and then get eaten by a polar bear
that's a tough guy and you did starve to
death you did starve to death well there
you go that kid is losing his hair look
at that look at how harsh that was yeah
look at that
we still have sweet haircut yeah that is
that is well you're never bathing you're
never able to do anything you have to
live well don't be an ass well yeah then
those aren't those are on story short
rain don't be an Eskimo now reindeer
parkas I would move to where it's warm
I'd be like guys I'm getting a boat yeah
it's a tough gig tough gig get some
current events guys amazing I've got a
few if it's about us sometimes I'm gonna
freak the [ __ ] out so port for the
fountain kid comes from manscape don't
you got a balls bush do you got a bush
like a boomer over here your bus just a
boomin well guess what jingle balls to
the walls felon listen up jingle balls
to the walls jingle your balls on the
wall don't have on trim pubes don't do
it man it's time to gear up and get
yourself the gift of shaving this
holiday season I'm talking about the
manscape perfect package 2.0 package now
dude you get a package you get the
perfect 2.0 lawn mower that trims you
around your dick piece don't you look
nice like a mole rat you so don't look
like your dad's bush or boomers buzz
like a squirrel and a bush yeah then you
get some deodorant for your nuts you get
that the ball Shaffer deodorant yep and
then guess what else you get manscape
boxer briefs that's right he keeps your
junk feeling fresh all damn day it's
time to upgrade those overused pair of
boxers to man escapes high-performance
anti chafing boxer brief tis the season
to get your dick right manscape it is
the way to go get it for your dad your
brother is your [ __ ] mom
grandpa tis the season get that yeah
penis right the manscaping sent off free
shipping with the coach fighter and
manscaped
dot-com your balls will thank you
manscape calm use the code fighter get
20% off clean up your not to make Santa
proud this year well guess what I'm
wearing roan underwear right now
dude you're owned up I got rowned shorts
I got rowned shirts
I got ruined everything I was actually
with their own owner this weekend in New
York City you roll him out and i'ma tell
you right now I got a chance not only I
got a package of rowned clothing it is
without a doubt the best quality
exercise clothing and the best looking
you can buy yeah engineered for
unparalleled quality and comfort okay
guys we're gonna do this read but they
have no idea rone makes something for
the modern man regardless of the
occasion all right whether whatever
you're doing maybe you're on a flight
you're in the office you're at home
whatever you want to do you want to look
fly man cool they offer everything from
pants polo short shirts they're all
lightweight comfortable and ready
wrinkle free unlike this guy mr. Ringle
frame but it's true you can look like
you can wear them anywhere but you also
can use them to work out it's good for
any weather workplace weekend barbecue
whatever you want to do man go to Rome
comp slash fighter today and use the
promo code fighter to get 20% off your
first purchase that's Rho and EECOM
slash fighter promo code fighter for 20%
off road comm slash fighter never heard
anything like that in my life I just
want to say that I've actually never
heard anything like that it snapped my
head around all right now if you're
gonna do that what you have to do right
and I would impede it with after wearing
diapers here's what happens is it's a
onesie I pee in the sink knit lesson
there's nothing more satisfying to me
when I paint the Sun I feel like a
Mangal
you feel like I'm on I feel like a biker
day yeah I could just do something bad
you want that about piss where you want
yeah dude peeing outside or Pino think
nothing about it
they'll disappoint chin is they're
peeing this thing I'm never gonna walk
let's sink oh my god watch my water dude
I'm sure dropped something for clean it
dude
any trip they'll be snitching either
chin they'll be telling not to tell
anyone but I'll know and it's the same
guy he farted so loud
well you know what he did he took a [ __ ]
his pants
he pushed and took a [ __ ] and went off
right I was like oh something's but what
it sounds like a bar iiiii snap my head
cats gonna throw up
look at her she's gonna throw up hey in
your necks all [ __ ] up so you're all
my next up are some oh my oh wow wow
your fart hurt my neck that's what
happened man that was incredible it had
layers to it but buh-buh-buh-buh-buh
like that boom like it you know it sound
like it sounded like a [ __ ] it
sounded like a large person falling down
steps in a van football gear - would the
football player fall downstairs that
that that thought the doge man thank you
so as i can hurt your [ __ ] and wow I
can alright let's go to some current
events can you shut your mouth about how
could he tell you I just know so have
you guys seen the brand new Tesla truck
I dig the truck to me I've been doing
hard on Tesla I dig the trucks that
concept though they're not gonna
actually know they're doing it right now
which is it 39,000 starting off that's
yeah
starting off 39 you don't be oh you
don't own the first generation Tesla
armored glass yeah and it has armored
glass they revealed this truck over the
weekend and Elon Musk was there and told
the speaker to throw it was like some
sort of like ball at the window to show
something like that something round and
heart must be bulletproof
it's called their new armored glass and
it's supposed to be super resilient so
the speaker says are you sure do you
want me to
throw this and Ilan says yes so this is
my promise you can't get out of it and
you can't like what what about when
you're no rap no no that's not the
problem here's the problem good play
this yeah you old thoughts yeah leave
this yeah well you know muss goes off he
barely threw it he goes well then go
through okay I think it looks sweet it's
just embarrassing for him but also this
was the concept so it's like no one told
him that the windows aren't bulletproof
yet like did you think oh they're not
yeah no this is just it's a [ __ ] demo
bro we're gonna power through the
goddamn windows because that was a very
lame throw yeah that was a toss I dig
the truck though but yeah that's the new
Tesla truck
yeah people wanna see whether you would
hate but can I see you guys driving and
stuff that thing is amazing oh yeah that
might be my next car nothing no no why
it's not man certain things are for you
but I want it's not for boomers but I
like no but I want it oh I love this
this is my boy Miro go down what's his
name dad mayor de Muro
Doug de Muro gives the best car
breakdowns out of anything any car you
have see if he's done it he he's a super
nerd but damn is he good at it yeah I
feel like this is for boomers it looks
sweet I will buy that Tesla it's 40
grand I will buy one when are they
available Oh buy one right now what I
think it's already on pre-order I'm not
sure yeah that's the you gonna come home
and be deliver looks like it yeah it's
just super clean oh it's got a weird
steering well now I won't be buying that
I think that's the concept Siri all
right definitely not for me yeah
but the body's supposed to be I do like
that it has the armored glass well
apparently not I live really digging
though yeah everyone thought was gonna
hate I'd actually love it yeah you can
order yours now
really oh yeah what does it come it's
got a ramp oh my son would love that
those are the real that's pretty young
sales to be it's not for me nothing but
right not for you yeah it's not for
boomers I'm not a Boomer right now not
it's 40 grand
oh nice yeah yeah I'll buy one yeah then
you trick it out nah leave it like that
yeah I think based off of when you
placed your order and when it's
confirmed they'll give you a date to
when you can receive it I'll do that for
it's very interesting that's cool it's
hilarious the windows you guys off
mother [ __ ] someone got fired no hundred
percent what else yet so I think we
talked about this a while ago Burger
King came out with their version of the
vegetarian vegan like whopper burger
with the impossible burger and this past
weekend they got a lawsuit filed from a
vegan man who says that it's not
actually a vegan burger because they
cook the impossible burger on the same
grill as their regular burgers oh so you
get grease from them mm-hmm so it's also
well know that would you know where the
we're doing well as a society when
people are that particular about that's
the problems so those are the problems
that in America we have that issue and
in places like I don't know Afghanistan
Somalia and North Korea there have sort
of Hong Kong right now issues that I
read yeah yeah also Brian here's the
thing let's say you walked in today I
went hey would you over the weekend like
dude you know what I've been a vegan I
didn't tell you I've been a vegan for a
while I went to Burger King
they were grilling my vegan burger on
the same grill that they cooked the
regular whoppers I'm suing them I'm like
oh no yeah we go why you we can't be
and can't be friends any mic cuz you're
a loser yeah we can't be friends in it
but you know it's it's a it's it's a
contamination it's a form of purity
people who are into this it's a form of
it's like you have contaminated my get
it might be algae sure yeah sure your
beliefs is it's not even it's not an
allergist okay you but you're still but
you're still giving money to
establishment that thank you
it's an Millie house man yes thank you
so y'all ready you're so ready
that's your supporter a good point but
and then also very good point I clean
that grill no but it's a very good point
since you've got a Burger King yeah so
you're jumping me but you give that
organization that swatters see how many
how many [ __ ] cows and a haze hey hey
burger can head shake give the job
chicken tenders deep fried snot but
still they say it's chicken for Burger
King yeah yeah oh well how many cows
does McDonald's killed and I think
that's I let's do that how many cows
killed they no doesn't own a
slaughtering account but we can tell you
that we use about seventy thousand
pounds of beef I mean 190,000 pounds of
beef daily so go hundred how much does a
cowboy average cow weighs 1,200 pounds
her 9,000 divided by 12 oh yeah it sure
would be a big-ass counter I think
that's about we'll find out but I think
they worry about 12 hours higher 58.3 3
I feel like they're killing more than a
hundred fifty eight maybe each store how
much does a cow way at slaughter I'm
sure we can go to how many uh no just
type in how many how many cows died a
day due to burn from you see what that
cow waise that's gonna come up die a day
okay how many how many cows die a day in
the US 800,000 undred thousand cows are
killed every day that's a lot and now
you're going to Burger King and they
make up a good majority of that then
McDonald's the rest of the [ __ ] paths
how much is a cow a I just want to say
if I was curious you're still stuck on
that huh yeah how much you think what
you think doing you want to guess first
I'm gonna say 1200 pounds only because I
know they're so big I must say I must
say an elk weighs in between 900 1,100
pounds okay i'ma go 1,100 I'll say 800
let's see 2,400 pounds to hear God
that's a bull female cows 1660 the
[ __ ] big dick dude that's weight cows
we can wave a thousand nothing smallest
breed average from our thousand cheers
hairy calves are much smaller but even
when they are born they still weigh a
whopping eighty five pounds oh man
they're cute as [ __ ] do 800 thousand
cows murder daily and you're crying cuz
the Burger King put your [ __ ] veggie
burger on the same grill yeah but you
gave him six dollars didn't you
you gave him six dollars if you're a
real vegan you a mean touching that you
wouldn't be going in to know your seed
that I saw a document around Bansky on
banner
yeah the street artist yes is it what
ink see you take a look at the his
McDonald's it had this this his he put
this huge statue in front of me yeah
house did you see what he did at
Disneyland - okay these are those I
think he's in the house no no McDonald's
yeah take a look at that watch buddy
watch the video oh it's a video
yeah you got a guy out there just this
one this one this one yeah yeah guys out
there the guy was out there [ __ ]
they're gonna bounce right before you as
his sculpture entitled she was shine
dating from the summer of 2013
depicting the powerful and the guy was
out there that he hired a guy out there
to polish his shoes and his ridiculously
oversized
shoes are popped to it fine shine right
in front of McAllister they weren't too
happy with you laugh cause he looks
Donald he looks so mad in J McDonald's
1950 thick fiberglass version and also
alright what else we got
I love Banksy though show the bagger you
know no one knows what he looks like I
know they still don't they still don't
know that's incredible that's incredible
if I'm a dude I'm still live here Banksy
well now when you do when they see like
they'd whitewash over wrists over [ __ ]
now they steal it now people get out
there and one minute and they take it
down for themselves hmm all right next
one so about two days ago there was a
Labrador that jumped into its owner's
car apparently the car was still running
and he somehow got the car into reverse
and he was doing donuts around the
cul-de-sac for a little under an hour of
course buddy yeah yeah before someone
like actually noticed called the police
and they ended up having police officers
and firefighters come to like somehow
stop the car without hurting the dog
that's that's actually and they actually
got some footage of it the owner came
out and he wanted to stay anonymous but
he said that he was out of the car the
car was still running and somehow his
dogs jumped in it doesn't make any sense
though I think what happened was the dog
was already in the car he left the car
running went inside to do something or
first girl who's announcing a news
anchor
Fox for a look that's it let's have it
let's let's play this dog doesn't love a
car right that's badonk right behind the
wheel well some Port st. Lucie neighbors
watched this dog stuck inside of a car
spinning in Reverse let's talk to
neighbors who said the dog didn't seem
to mind this ride at all there's nothing
something cheesy right hearted drivers
might not have the best reputation so an
annus table saw this gray sedan spinning
in Reverse outside her window in Port
st. Lucie it was a better driver than a
lot of them I've seen she wasn't
immediately
surprise but police started showing up
and then I saw another cop car the cop
car and then she realized the car had
just one occupants a black lab rather
contents in the front sleek even hit me
I thought they should give the dog
license to drive police say the owner
stepped out at the car and the dogs
somehow the car into reverse our police
was like could I ran that car at 9 miles
an hour finally stop this dogs Joyride
by punching a passcode into the driver's
side door to get inside but now before
that dog first took out this mailbox a
trash can and some bricks in front of a
home she's high but the best news the
dog wasn't hurt at all in fact pretty
happy after his first and hopefully last
solo dog died of dizziness they always
have to do some cheesy like yeah not all
dogs go to heaven Becky back to you yeah
it's always something super lame I
[ __ ] true all the balls are dead
what's that thing you posted about well
I was molested by my Uncle Sam the
comics I don't know
oh that have you seen it let me see it
what was that on my Instagram yeah
because you I would there's nothing you
know morning mark Normand yeah yeah the
morning morning medias destroys your
soul yeah so he's on there and they go
have your puppy this is live this is
live
molested by an uncle and that gave me
superpowers
yes he was funny so how far I go oh okay
this is the worst there's so morning
despite what the see how they are where
they talk to you and then they're like
how are you good to see the name is
looking at you and I've seen nice to see
ya know well Bryan Callen is here and he
is a comedian things just get much
funnier he is known as the coach on the
Goldbergs and he hailed from MADtv and
we're very happy to hear how are you
Brian
he's nothing worse than like I can stick
in my mouth you this hey Brian what can
people expect for you to coma this
weekend you're all this who if I ever
ask yourself yeah I'm gonna hang myself
if I'm Marinette why because I mean come
on me with piano wire yes there's
nothing funny really calm and there's
this Brian's dead good news is I'm
taking over there's nothing better
well Sam and I haven't always been funny
unless there's a kid and he was funny so
I get it
who is he I don't know dude Sam's a
beast
superbee obviously yeah that's funny
super beast that's great
what else you got are you guys okay with
a couple sad ones there's not really a
lot of good happy stuff ourselves
Thanksgiving let's get sad
let's kill some [ __ ] turkeys well
Brennan you're the one that showed me Oh
after so as you know Ania Blanchard is
Walt Harris is his daughter the UFC
fighter
heavyweight and then she's been missing
for a while she was a kidnapped and then
apparently they seemed to have found
remains that might be her horrible it's
the worst thing I guess yeah she's
better wait so she was kidnapped from
convenience store she's Walt Harris is
the UFC heavyweight stepdaughter so she
was kidnapped she was a college student
she's kidnapped at a
mean store two men Ghadir they found the
cumin gotcha man got it they what they
both human and then were arrested but
connected to the crime but one guy was
arrested first and then another one yes
they found in her car but there's foul
play her blood was in the car
life-threatening life let and then they
found the one dude they arrested him and
then this guy Lee this [ __ ] Punk kill
him so they think it's her they believe
it's her which is very very sad and
something else to this is which is
terrible is there's a witness that saw
everything they noticed something
happening and he wanted to do something
or he was thinking she should do
something but his wife had told him at
the time like no don't say anything
don't get involved
Tom ass and then he was like that's
clearly regressive outdoors yes you
[ __ ] of course you see you gotta say
some woman you [ __ ] yeah how do you
not help out put that put a band witness
abduction
why said stay out of it that [ __ ] should
be in prison
this poor girl yeah
and these [ __ ] just grabbed her
and put her on stroll up chicken right
there no no right there the horrible was
just made in our bama court Wednesday
when officials are trying to prove
forcibly shoved in nineteen year old
Anna into her car in October 23rd
oh [ __ ] sakes man nothing worse but yeah
terrible ending to this I don't know
Walt Harris I don't know her yet uh if I
show you a picture you'll know who
fought Werdum on short notice
he's fight alistair overeem poor family
it's recognizing stud
yeah put put the put Walt Harris in that
[ __ ] cell with those guys yeah well
Harris does armor him yeah he's a bad
[ __ ] so athletic yeah you see
what happens huh give give giving the
wall Harris so wall Harris can pull his
head off his spine agree I wish he
wanted that he actually requested that
he said that on dr. Phil that's he did
yeah like he wants to do really badly so
obviously horrible yeah yeah Jenn she's
so pretty too horrible
yeah I was gonna show another shadow
we'll just pass it no give me another
all right you guys don't know her but
it's a Korean pop star another one
committed suicide no Khalid warning
another one
Wow she's so pretty oh she was super
cute and like she was a bunch of she's
not a bunch of like variety shows she
had a really like cute dimples and smile
and everything really trying person yeah
well there's still an investigation but
they they're pretty much guessing it's
suicide
so you know Harry Morton whoo yeah we
were just thought ideally I worked with
Harry for a long time I did yes so so he
owned his father brought hard rock and I
used to do beatriz madhouse oh yeah me
and dog we do everything to shut down
I'm sorry his Beacher's Madhouse there
anymore
uh it's not my my and my wife when I met
my wife she was us I think she was think
she might have a semi-date with Harry
but they were just it didn't work out he
was really nice and he was a good guy
man
really good guy oh you thought the guy
who died yeah I knew his only 39 yeah I
knew Harry you know I mean I would see
him every weekend for two years and he
was always a great guy man but it's dead
you know he had his his father his
grandfather started Morton skate
Steakhouse his father owned Hard Rock
yeah so Harry Harry darted pink taco
yeah and he and and and you know he was
trying to find his way it's not easy
when you got those there's a big shoes
to fill
you know and in that way I mean in terms
of making your name for it's gonna be a
rough for life with yeah of course it
could but but what's interesting about
it is it doesn't mean you're happy no no
he'd be about a twenty five million
dollar home in Beverly Hills yeah yeah
that well there by the way was it
suicide drug overdose to me now if
that's all yeah well I'm guessing it's
because this half sister in 2005 she
died of a drug overdose yeah well you
know you know if you're a bit in it's
off the odds are hands - yeah but you
know if your parents are billionaires
you're 400 times more likely for died
400 cent more likely how about that how
about [ __ ] we got no purple integrity
yet but you like you know that you're
playing with house money all the time so
there's no sense of accomplishment
good-looking dude [ __ ] all the hot
girls go through the list of girls he
dated Jennifer Aniston Lindsay Lohan
Demi Moore he dated already Spears
yo yeah look man IIIi thought he was a
you know for what it's worth I I knew
him well enough to say I thought he was
a good guy doing Beacher's Madhouse one
my favorite place on earth it's still
there I definitely there are two years
I'm not a girl I did for a long time
there man's a good old and he was uh he
was the guy who kind of owned it or kind
of like you know and he started rehab I
think at Hard Rock whatever was called
it was like had Oh a casino right yeah
well here's what's interesting so Harry
Morton underwent a knife free under the
knife to repair a deviated septum just
weeks before his death so I wonder if
it's a mixture of pain killers sleeping
that's all I'm imagining like a Heath
Ledger type situation you feel me yeah
or even just regular prescription
painkillers I could have killed any feel
god I know I didn't you know I know I'm
back in the day I never knew him to get
drunk or do drugs or I mean I was with
him in Vegas at night you know would
have been going on so I don't know I
don't know we'll find out later in the
week I'm sure that's feting all or
painkillers I'm sure it's mixing the
ones you should it and you you know game
over
it's a bummer God's not for hunt more
likely 407 madness the best thing to do
with your if you're a billionaire is
take your kid and make him join the
Marines you're gonna be in the Marines
for four years I'm cutting you off
something you gotta do something to let
you do something to make them I don't
know I don't know I don't have them live
with that suppose for a year that's not
a bad idea with the Inuit like my buddy
Sam gonna send them with a bunch of
seals there you go
waking up early crying in and out just
so you can prove that you did it Erik
Prince did that put him on they
convinced you started Blackwater
he had crazy money Erik Prince came from
crazy Melia's he was like I'm gonna go
be a Navy SEAL I'll see you guys later
that's cool no let's get Jim here's a
better story
these Chinese surgeons were on a plane
this is badass you saw it and there's
older men older man who had
overgrown prostate is that right a
prostate like something was obviously
wrong couldn't piss he was good yeah
shock gotta milk that thing dude you
gotta get in there through he stuck a
[ __ ] thing they took a a hose for the
oxygen mask yep it's a syringe stick
into its bladder and that dude okay so
guys walk it out that side [ __ ]
that amazing Chinese doctor sucked it up
sucked it out and save that guy now and
by the way had to suck it in his mouth
and spit it out for half an hour around
yeah that's a good time that's a good
dude man
that's an amazing yeah there's a little
bit of a video here oh it was so good to
see ya that's him son he's dr. Ahn so
singing it out of that bottle Wow Wow
cuz he knew the guy was gonna die
yeah they puncture it wouldn't go out on
his own so he had to siphon it there me
ciphering peepee what a gangster dude
save a life you know what a gangster is
right that's a hero whatever had
[ __ ] quiet hero yes piss breath
but what oh good I've been gay quiet
hero leave that a godmother we get the
hero suckin he's got his mask on a
surgical mask
- probably cuz he might not need it
though you know well that's a lot of
Chinese people I noticed where sir all
the UM Plains and soda soda Duncan
Trussell I saw him with his girl they
were wearing of any one I was like
Duncan what he don't he don't be a [ __ ]
he was wearing a [ __ ] but it was half
on that's the worst
what else you got this have fun one more
it's a very nice one right here look
this is a German Shepherd with dwarfism
so it's gonna look like a puppy holy
[ __ ] all of its life this is two years
old I god I think it's cute right holy
balls can you buy this guy I mean
usually adopt them because people I
gotta take there's a [ __ ] dog out
there there's Joey now and then every
now and then you have my quirky so much
so much but the [ __ ] isn't
always thought he's like he looks just
like that whoa yeah
he's cutest [ __ ] hey we've been over
this
my Corgi you know my corgis adore let me
take him up my Corgi is adorable but he
follows me or
and all he does this off he just follows
me around and he looks at me keeps
poking him he's like what he's like this
what like I'm like I'm not taking you
for a walk we're having out nah
like always I get it it's actually a
little on your nerves I sit down and
tell him my lap you let me take him out
no he's the I love that dog all right
you don't ever say he looks like that
though he's cuter glad my corgis cuter
all right hey please don't don't put
your court younger I know don't do that
hi now that's so dumb he's definitely
working everybody is that it dudes
that's pretty much it it's a Monday guys
it's Monday nice the [ __ ] rock Monday
and I appreciate it
now you guys can show me am brace
awesome your [ __ ] Monday's right
we'll see we'll see all our fans the
guys got tickets the gals and guys at
the ice house Wednesday Wednesday night
and um see some great comic store
tonight with Sam triple you doing that
show I'm not dude
okay I gotta be rested for my kid I'm
just idle Sam I can't write and that's a
[ __ ] Sam shows tomorrow night [ __ ]
Tuesday night Tuesday night not tonight
Thank You April
I mean December 21st celebrity theater I
am in Phoenix and then Boston 12 31 19
years Eve I can't wait
Wilbur theater get your tickets now
thank you don't expel yeah Nashville on
January make sure you do those if you
love them dude I know make sure you're
doing and we'll talk about that in a bit
all right
next week Kansas City improv just Friday
Saturday two shows Friday to show
Saturday those shows almost sold out
that's Kansas City improv next week try
and barbecue and saw I need a good gym
to get my bike gun let me know then
Atlantic City Borgata casino December
14th one night only one show I'm doing
comedy then sticking around with you
guys and watching the big UFC
pay-per-view coming out for that La Hoya
December 19th through the 21st The
Comedy Store La Jolla Oklahoma is
December 27th Tulsa December 28th and
then January gets pretty froggy as well
January I'm at Foxwoods casino January
10th Wilber Boston January 11th we're
almost sold out we're gonna add a show
if you guys sell that [ __ ] out in the
next week or so so get your tickets now
Boston January 11th tickets that tea fat
K for Brian and myself is that it dude
that's him brother this the fun kid
route